بظروف صعبه وتوقيت بعيد عن الامثل يتحول
الشتات في الحروب الى ازمه قابله للتصدير
سريعا الى دول الجوار صراع الجنرلين دفع
نحو 15 الف نازح من السودانيين وجنوب
السودانيين للعبور الى الضفه الجنوبيه في
اقل من اسبوعين عدد سيصل لمئه وثمانين
الفا في ثلاثه اشهر فقط اذا استمر
الاقتتال وفقا لممثله الامم المتحده في
جنوب السودان الامن شبه المنعدم كان
الدافع الرئيسيا لهروب الاله في الى وجهه
ليست اكثر امنا وفقا لما تشير اليه منظمه
الامم المتحده فرحله الفرار الممتده ل500
كيلو متر تقريبا ملغمه بالمخاطر تبدا من
العاصمه بما يتوفر من وسائل المواصلات او
السير مشيا في احيان والتعرض لخطر هجوم
مسلح الى حين الوصول الى ولايه الابيض
اقرب نقطه حدوديه جنوبيه للخرطوم هناك حيث
يعيش نحو 300 الف جنوب سوداني في المخيمات
جلهم نزح من حرب اهليه داميه في بلد لا
يزال خمسه وسبعون بالمئه من سكانه يعتمدون
على مساعدات انسانيه تتكفل بثلاثه وعشرين
بالمئه فقط من احتياجاتهم وضع يزداد خطوره
في ظل هشاشه اتفاق السلام الموقعي عام
2018 بين فصائل الجنوب والترقب لاول
انتخابات في تاريخ البلاد تجري نهايه
العام المقبل وليس مستبعدا ان تخلق حرب
الشمال فرصه جديده لتنشيط جماعات مسلحه
يلجا اليها القاده المتمردون الغاضبون من
حكومه سيلفاكير رئيس دوله جنوب السودان
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات